[Applaudissements]
perdait alors moi j'ai choisi aussi jean
michel aulas écoles et guay aujourd'hui
comme ça aujourd'hui c'est la fête de
l'amour
je vous le dis alors que ben oui bah
l'amour est basse et voilà c'est ici
voilà donc ça vous pourrez choisir
merci michel enrico macias était le
mendiant de l'amour alors attendez pas
ce que je demande jean-michel à la fin
de la déclaration d'amour de gilles
demain vous allez devoir passer parce
qu'on va refaire une nuit vous allez
devoir passer la nuit ou avec daniel où
étions nous on lui dirait ou avec gilles
vous allez nous dire avec qui vous
choisissez passer la nuit d'accord il y
avait la déclaration daniel maintenant
c'est gilles ses deux salles deux
ambiances à surveiller le salon dessange
deux salves jean-michel enrico macias
était le mendiant de l'amour vous êtes
l'orphelin de la saint valentin
aujourd'hui plus que jamais je pense à
vous à la hongrie allongé sur votre lit
en train de vous dire encore un 14
février tout seul et ça ce n'est plus
supportable pour moi jean michel oui je
vous ai mis un haut conseil de classe
mais ça c'était aux professionnels que
je m'adressais l'homme lui vaut au moins
deux jean-michel là et je vous promets
jean-michel plus jamais je ne vous
laisserai seul alors si vous le désirez
je vais vous offrir un immense bouquet
de roses
oui je vais vous inviter au restaurant
ans les yeux dans les yeux que vous
pourrez enfin choisir s'il vous plaît de
rester plus longtemps avec moi si je
conseille de les promouvoir gilles et
moi c'est que ça ne va pas jean michel
vous avez été séduit ben ben je crois
que c'est la chance de la ville daniel
[Rires]
comme ça q
[Applaudissements]